that microcosm that what played in the
microcosm of nietzsche is what is
playing the macrocosm of humanity
a hundred
and fifty years later
um
i just hope we don't go mad
when we realize that we are failing to
pull transcendence downwards and try to
make it palpable it's not in the nature
of the thing to be that
it is us who have to transcend ourselves
it it doesn't make sense to put
transcendence into us
it's like pulling the word the world
into the prison no it's not gonna happen
you cannot pull the world into your
prison cell all you can do is
break out it's not going to work the
other way around it didn't work for
nietzsche
it's not going to work for us
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
hi welcome to our christ today i'm
joined once again by two gentlemen and
most likely admire jonathan pajot and dr
bernardo castro jonathan is a french
canadian icon carver a public speaker
and a youtuber exploring the symbolic
patterns that underlie our experience of
the world how these patterns emerge and
come together manifest in religion art
and popular culture he's also the editor
of the orthodox arts journal and host of
the symbolic world blog and podcast
renato then is the executive director of
essentia foundation his work has been
leading the modern renaissance of
metaphysical idealism the notion that
reality is essentially mental
he's a phd in philosophy and another phd
in computer engineering
so then they just to begin gentlemen do
you have any i suppose preliminary
questions or statements about each
other's work that you'd like to ask or
to share then well i i haven't read
bernardo's books but i i i have had a
chance to listen to many of his lectures
and listen to many of his discussions
because it's when i'm carving it's
that's the perfect medium for me um and
so i think that i
first of all i really appreciate this
let's say not just what bernardo's doing
but just this this moment i would say
this return to understanding the
importance of mind and the importance of
consciousness
in the way we experience the world and
the way that the world kind of lays
itself out i think that there's a lot of
points of contact with what i'm doing
i think that i definitely come
to it from a specifically religious
point of view and so it's on that
particular point that i would have
questions for bernardo i i heard him
talk about let's say the manner in which
the the primary mind or the you know the
divine mind he probably doesn't use the
word divine mind like the primary mind
of how it develops into multiple minds
as a form of dissociation
and so i would have some questions on
that
how he sees that in relation for example
to
the christian notion that there's rather
a giving that this kind of giving and
then there's a notion of love which
binds the
minds together and binds them towards
the uh
the primary mind and so that would
that's actually my biggest question is
is related to that uh but i'm sure we
could have many many things to talk
about
yeah i think uh the importance of
symbolism and iconography is vastly
underestimated in our society today so
from that perspective i love jonathan's
work
i have a room in my house it's not the
one i'm in right now but i have a room
in my house filled with orthodox
christian iconography
um i'm not an orthodox
christian
i don't consider myself a a person
aligned with any particular religious
tradition maybe because of my education
my origins and my father was very
scientifically oriented secular
but over the course of my life i've
grown to appreciate
the depth and the subtlety and nuance of
symbolism and religious iconography and
today i
deliberately make it a part of my life a
discreet small part of my life but an
important one nonetheless so from that
perspective i appreciate very much what
jonathan has been doing all these years
and um there's so many different things
that i'm interested in talking about
with you guys and points of convergence
but i do want to lead the competition
too much so i actually have less notes
that well less concentrated notes notes
than i usually do a little more probably
overall so i'm just wondering is there
any particular direction that you would
like to go in
um
jonathan i suppose since you mentioned
you had a few points that you wanted to
clarify i suppose with fernando
well i think that that the question that
i mentioned is really my big question uh
for bernardo i think
what i tend to
notice in in his system is that the
divisions of of mind is something like a
i wouldn't say uh an accident or or
maybe that there seems to be something
that is not particularly positive about
the division of mind maybe that's the
best way to phrase it uh and so
that's what i would like to for him to
to talk about a little because
i mean an example i can give is that if
a human experiences dissociation
we would want to heal that dissociation
it seemed like we would want to to
resorb these opposing personalities or
opposing aspects into at least a
centralized
uh centralized consciousness that can
encompass both of them uh and so if that
is the main image that he uses for the
manifestations of multiple minds uh is
it does is does that mean that existence
itself the way we experience it is
something of a scandal like the gnostics
tended to uh
tended to to uh display it or is there
something is there something more that's
possible in that model so that's my
biggest question
i don't think it's a scandal i don't
think it's a mistake i mean in eastern
traditions you hear a lot
the notion of maya or illusion being
associated with some kind of error
something went wrong at some point
and the best we can do is to just you
know
bear this illusion illusory life for as
long as it lasts but the better yet is
to get away from this while in life
and to sort of uh
transcend
this world because it's a mistake i
i don't relate to that very well
um i don't i may relate more to the
gnostic notion but only in so far as the
demiurges itself part of god
and we just use different words for
different aspects of one and the same
thing
um
i don't use a religious language
normally for two reasons jonathan one is
it's honestly the way i approach it more
secular language it's it's it's closer
to my background to how i was educated
uh both at home and and you know at
university and my work life and so on
and so forth
and the other reason is
religious language is symbolic and that
means two things one
uh it's much more it's much farther
reaching it reaches much much further
than than than secular language that's
that's the importance of it that's the
the the indispensable aspect of it
that's what it does that nothing else
can do
but it's also very amenable to
misinterpretation so if i start talking
about god or the divine mind i don't
know what people
what people will interpret my words to
mean probably there are seven and a half
billion definitions of god out there so
that's the other reason but in this
company
i i feel very
comfortable talking about the divine
mind instead of
a specially unbound field of
subjectivity
i'm i'm pretty okay with that because i
i do identify these two things i think
the world's religious traditions are not
uh a reflection of mental illness or or
wish which fulfilling or and you know i
think they reflect profound and
ultimately true intuitions that the
human mind has always had
and what i call the universal mind
is bound to be what many people
throughout history have referred to as
the divine mind now dissociation as the
mechanism through which the divine mind
becomes our individual minds
the kinosis of the divine mind if we can
talk start talking more religious
language
i reserve
publicly i reserve judgment about why
that happened if i'm pressed against the
wall i would say well
it happened because it's one of the
things that are inherent in the
potentials of nature and given enough
time it's bound to happen for the same
reason that a volcano is bound to erupt
that a tornado is bound to happen
uh you know it
that uh um i don't know that the star
goes supernova
uh these are the things that can happen
in nature because nature is what it is
and therefore they are bound to happen
at some point in dissociation or life
with its extrinsic appearance is just
one of those things but if you ask me
more deeply and more personal personally
in in this smaller group where we are
now
i don't think it's an accident i don't
think it's meaningless i don't think
it's pathological either
um i use dissociation more as a
metaphor than as a literal
attribution
of of a pathological condition to the
divine mind um
for us it's
pathological in the sense that it may be
maladaptive we have non-pathological
levels of dissociation all the time
every time you forget something you're
dissociated when you dream you are
dissociated those are not pathological
they are adaptive so i don't attribute
the pathological aspect of it to the to
the divine mind and i even
suspect that the association has to do
with the felt
telos a a felt
purpose
that is
experienced by the divine mind and
expresses itself
in the form of life dissociation
how do you see that how do you know i i
think i mean i think it's great that
we're talking because i've heard you
mostly talk in terms of
use use the the more technical language
and so i was wondering what it implied
to you i mean the way that i see it
i i have a more i really have it
what you could call a christian
nondualist perspective that might be the
best way to explain the way that i think
i think that there's
that the way that it is it's expressed
is that unity and multiplicity have a
manner of coexisting
and so in the same manner that there are
multiple multiple aspects of my
attention possible attention or possible
aspects of my consciousness and those
can be if i am
in the proper
properly oriented those can be gathered
into me it doesn't mean that i'm
explicitly conscious of all
those aspects but they they can be
gathered into me even though i'm not
let's say explicitly conscious of all
the possibilities and i think that in
that same manner
that is how we
fit into what we would call
transpersonal beings
uh whether it be families or or
countries but then also how aspects of
us function in transpersonal beings as
well like virtues
you know and and i have no problem with
the notion of hierarchies of beings
hierarchies of angels hierarchies of
gods
but that all of that ultimately
is never
outside of the of the divine mind and
that it exists
in in love within the the divine mind
and that it is it becomes pathological
to the extent that
when when a mind dissociates itself
completely from its higher
participations that's when it becomes
something like uh pathology and i think
that that's what we see
in the uh in the image of the story of
the fall of adam and eve uh and and in
other uh traditions i think the
important thing for me is unlike what
you mentioned before the the notion of
eastern
uh some eastern traditions or gnostic
traditions that
that see multiplicity as something of a
of a scandal in itself or something of a
of a deep illusion or sinful in in the
very fact of its multiplicity i i i it
seems to me that the christian or the
highest christian answer that has been
given which i find interesting is that
it it seems to resolve that with the
notion of kenosis and love this this
idea of this self-offering
um and but then there's also this return
which happens at the same time in inside
god um
and so you can see it eschatologically
in scripture right from the beginning to
the end you can kind of see that full
movement from procession to return
uh but it never implies that
it never implies that it annoys
multiplicity like the return into god
this is something you see in the church
fathers all the time that they'll say
things like you know
still say things like you know in heaven
saint paul is saint paul saying peter is
saying peter there is no loss
of
of personhood
but there is rather the fullness of
participation in in god to the extent
that that's possible for a person to to
do so so multiplicity always continues
to exist within within the the unity of
the divine mind i don't that makes sense
i i never know if we have the same
language but it's dangerous to talk too
long sometimes
now i i agree largely with you perhaps
completely
with some nuances
dissociation is is a very subtle
mental process it's very difficult to
introspect into it and really pin down
its mechanisms and that's why my
colleagues in analytic philosophy have a
hard time
really embracing dissociation as the
solution to the so-called
decomposition problem how one mind can
seem to be many because they are looking
for something unambiguous and explicit
some some conceptually clear mechanism
that would explain how dissociation
happens how the appearance of
multiplicity can happen within a unified
otherwise unifying mind
and we don't have language for that or
or sufficiently developed conceptual
arsenals for that because everything is
so subtle the only thing one can appeal
to it is one's direct experience and i
have had the experience of resolving
certain dissociative states that i have
had for years
and in retrospect
and this will sound funny maybe some
maybe even sound contradictory
in retrospect
i know that i was both sides of that
dissociation like for the longest time
if you could if you would have asked me
in the past are you feeling this and
that i would have said no i don't feel
that at all that's not how i feel at all
it's that's not me it's not part of my
world today i look back and i realized
no i was feeling that way i was always
feeling that way i just didn't recognize
it to myself now how do you make sense
of this to somebody who has not had that
experience it's almost impossible our
vocabulary and conceptual arsenal are
they are still evolving to pin that down
but i agree with you
that multiplicity and unity
are not a dichotomy
it may sound like a dichotomy but it's a
false
dichotomy because our cognitive
apparatus is not yet equipped or maybe
sufficiently evolved to grasp what is
meant there uh only somebody who has had
dissociative identity disorder and has
been quote cured
uh will know that subtlety will know how
that can happen how multiplicity can
exist in a unity that never ended
um
the other thing another thing you said
that i i think is is is important
is uh
you talked about it as a christian
inheritance and it definitely is that
i would go even further and i would say
it's one of the key characteristics of
the western mind one of our
contributions to the world which is we
are engaged with
this world
um there are some streams even in the
christian tradition that tell us you
know this world is just some kind of
penance uh
life should be about what comes after
but by and large the western mind is
engaged we don't dismiss life on the
contrary we seek meaning in the world
and i think as i'm sure you do
that the world is not only pregnant with
meaning
it is the very expression of meaning
everything around us is not just the
thing in itself you know it's it's
merely that and we there is no such a
thing everything around us has an
extra hidden dimension of depth and
meaning
that far transcends surface appearances
and i think the western mind is very
interested in engaging with that as jung
put it
we don't try to get rid of the images
we try to relate to the images we we
don't just say oh it's maya it doesn't
matter forget about it wait for the next
life no no we engage with it we try to
find out
what the meaning of this whole thing is
and i think that's a very important
contribution of the western mind but
even the west has lost touch with that
fundamental stream of itself of its own
inheritance
i no i totally agree i think that
there it's almost like it's a there's a
perversion of that inheritance which is
which has become something like the
scientism that we deal with or this the
you know the the strange materialism
that we that we face it's almost like a
it's like an anti
a strange
the only way to say it is it's a strange
perversion of something which at the
outset was positive and that you find
and that's one of the reasons also why i
i really love iconography and i love the
orthodox tradition is because it has
maintained this notion of the
transfiguration and the resurrection
as two of the most central images that
is the possibility of fullness and the
possibility of
of seeing light in phenomena and not
comple not exactly like you said like
i'm gonna die get rid of this world and
and fly off to heaven but rather the
image the final eschatological image is
one of resurrection which is that all
aspects of reality are full
of of god ultimately not that they're
just resorbed into the into the one um
so no thanks for that that's that's
really helpful for me to understand your
thoughts definitely
and the other thing that i think is
part of our inheritance but we ourselves
have rejected it because of i don't know
some dialectic reaction to our own uh
inherent archetypes i don't know but uh
it's this notion that um
life is a matter of service
um and and therein lies our freedom
uh another seeming paradox and
contradiction but this notion that uh
you know it's the notion we perverted
when we turned prayer into a ritual for
telling god what to do
that
that's the thing that is perverted by
this modern phenomenon we turn to god
when we need something and then we go
follow a ritual to tell god okay this is
what you should do to help me out and we
completely forgot that it goes the other
way too
that there is a service to be rendered
to a divinity
through
this condition of being alive in this
world
um
and perhaps iconography and symbolism is
what we need to sort of
revitalize that part of our inheritance
that archetypal part of our inheritance
who wrote recently about this was peter
kingsley
uh he he he writes in a sort of
very particular way and he just said
yeah we
we sort of forgot and we don't care uh
anymore about what the divinity wants of
us
it's like yeah the divinity takes care
of itself
and and we just ask for stuff you know
we tell god what to do um
do you think
a symbolic life can help us recover that
that part of our inheritance
definitely and one of the things that i
been
emphasis emphasizing people is the
notion of participation in general one
of the things that the modern world has
brought to us is this idea of the
distance you know this entertainment
mode or this this kind of observer mode
in reality
um and i think that religious
participation let's say the liturgy for
example
i think that one of its functions and
obviously this is not the only function
for those people who are listening or
watching watching this but one of its
functions seems to be exactly what we
talked about in terms of resolving uh
dissociation that is the manner in which
we
if you if you look at the
progression of the liturgy it move it's
a moving in right of moving into this
holy place and a
a um at some point it says we represent
the angels and there's this note that
the angels come down and so there's a
movement towards
a recognition that we're all dancing
let's say we're all dancing together
around that which unifies us and one of
the things we need to do is engage in
this dance celebrate that which unifies
us and then received from it the seed or
the you know the the point that we that
all the
philosophers talk about this point that
joined holds the circle together that's
what we receive and then we move out and
we let's say bring that into the world
so that the world holds together so in
that sense that's why you'll see that
often you'll find theologians saying
things like the liturgy holds the world
together you know and i think that that
might seem like just a little bit of
hyperbole but
i think it really it really is just in
the same way that in engaging in a
family dinner
properly and and doing that with your
family you know engaging in that that
procession and that circumambulation
holds your family together
something like the liturgical
liturgical service is is a cosmic dance
which
which binds the world uh together and so
i think that and and it it's constantly
expressing this relationship between
unity and multiplicity the relationship
also to attention if you listen to an
orthodox energy you'll hear attend all
the time you know stand stand and attend
um and this idea of a sacrifice of
worship all these things i think that
participating there's a sense in which
at least in the christian vision
that participating that in participating
in that
is a way to actually experience
the the resolving of dissociation and
then be able to then internalize it so
that we can see even if not consciously
or not thought out we can then it will
be applied to your own life where just
as you love your brother and you notice
you know in this movement how you you
notice how all these other people are
images of god and we're all images of
each other we're bowing to each other we
do we do doing all these things and it's
bringing us together um
then we can notice in our own lives
these
dissociative aspects
i i completely agree with you
the liturgy
is a symbolic
playing out of a dance that is happening
all the time even even if we don't know
and the vast majority of people don't
know
i do think that the orthodox tradition
has preserved that a lot better than
the usual protestant or catholic church
that
some people still go to on sunday
because
some orthodox rituals for instance the
priests have their backs to the public
they face the divinity they face the
altar
and
these subtle little things are important
because
if they face the altar the message is uh
the priest is one of us
they are representing us
and and we are
trying to relate to the divinity
as opposed to the catholic priest who
stands on
the place where he stands
facing us with his back to the altar
and preaching moral codes
um
that hasn't worked for 2 000 years
and then after luther
we completely got rid of
symbolism altogether i mean i'm not here
to to chastise luther because he saw
several things
that that were true and and needed a
reaction he saw that the church was
becoming a temporal power as opposed to
a spiritual power he saw that clergy was
hypocritical
focused on money and sinning
uh he understood that
the people had to have more direct
participation in a relationship with
divinity so they should be able to read
the bible and not only have the priests
there's
full con controlling intermediaries for
a relationship with god so i understand
all that
but it went
so far that
some protestant rituals are now
sort of a mock-up of a trial
there is no symbolism is just
telling you what not to do all the time
um they even dress like judges
so
there is a tremendous loss that maybe
even religious institutions are guilty
of promoting yeah but i think i think
that with even your work or the work
that i'm seeing people like john
vervicky that uh that you've talked to
as well
and it seems like we're in a even what
jordan peterson has been doing seems
like there's a an interesting moment
right now and there's a moment in which
even secular people are capable of
suddenly noticing for example
the the ritualization of their daily
behavior that the idea of the informal
as being the place of authenticity uh
this has been
the disease of the of you know the west
from from i would say possibly from the
reformation for sure after that this
idea that that which is authentic is
when we are we are informal and this is
this is absurd because you as soon as
you realize how even your bad habits are
ritualized like everything that you
engage with anything that's teleological
has to be ritualized
that then all of a sudden you can think
okay so that's why we have
to have anything in common it has to be
ritualized you know or else you can't do
it in common and so as it seems like an
interesting moment and hopefully this
will grow i think even in the protestant
churches in the united states those that
are leading the edge you could say are
returning to a
somewhat of a
of a rich a ritualized sense of time
where they celebrate the different
feasts of the church and you know they
have more liturgy a little more form
formalism so i think that it's
we can't go any further than the rock
and roll concert uh rock and roll
concert and conference church
there's nowhere there's no nothing lower
we can go to and so hopefully it's all
appeal from here for many of the
churches
i i hope you are right i do think that
um
there is a psychological reason why
we've embraced banality so so thoroughly
you call it informa informality i rather
call it banality we've made everything
banal
everything is superficial and banal and
meaningless and nihilistic
and if i just put it like that and
everybody who is listening or watching
this will think well but of course
that's not what we wanted we don't want
banality
we want depth we want meaning
i think this is a superficial judgment
um i think
we do want banality
because it it
spares us
the confrontation with some great
terrors within
a banality absolves from responsibility
it absorbs absorbs from
the feeling of having to achieve
something
of having to render some form of service
achieve some kind of goal no there's
nothing there's nothing to achieve
nothing it's the unbearable lightness of
being of milan kundera it's so light it
floats with the breeze
we are anchored in nothing nothing has
any meaning nothing has any depth
i mean
there is a huge psychological payoff for
this
an enormous price our gargantua price
that's depression
and
in the way and then
it's all that stuff that we have an
epidemic after the addiction you know
this gazillion different patterns of
addictive living that we have today when
i say addiction i don't mean only
substance addiction i mean addiction to
distraction to television to buying
shoes to sex and porn to
everything eating meat and sugar these
are all addictions
um and because we we've lost
depth
and roots and meaning
we feel no responsibility
we do not we no longer fear
the experiential state after that death
because there is no such thing
but we lost our meaning and we
compensate with that with uh myriad
patterns of addictive behavior
so in a sense
we've secured the payoff
and we found a band-aid
to compensate for the price we pay yeah
that's distraction consumerism
television pornography eating
all this stuff
it is difficult to dislodge a
civilization from this local minimum
i don't think it happens without
major trauma it didn't happen after two
world wars
so that gives you an idea yeah no you're
right i don't think that we've dealt
with anything uh that happened in those
first world wars we're just we just were
shocked for two generations one you know
two generations and seems like all the
patterns are returning that's for sure
one of the things that i like to do is
to help people notice for example that
the patterns of addiction actually are
religious in nature they're just
distorted religious
patterns and that so once you see that
once you understand that you know like
if whatever bad habit you have
is is basically a form of liturgy um
it's just that it's one that that is
let's say that that spirals fast and
that runs out fast too it runs out of uh
of what it can offer you it's a and that
higher attention is better
um is better than these low
these these little uh these little
circles of of attention
absolutely i mean it's not for nothing
that we call alcohol spirit
there is there is a
deep root to this why alcohol is a
spirit because it puts you in an
inebriated state that the greeks would
would explain by saying well a spirit
took possession of me
so alcohol is the spirit uh
it is impossible for human beings it's
impossible for living beings
to get rid of the religious intuition
because it's at the root of the tree the
the intellect is the canopy it came much
later it's it's looking at the sun
and it doesn't see the dark and moist
environment where we arise from that
womb where we arrive arise from and
that's the religious intuition we can't
get rid of it all we can do is misplace
it and we misplace it all over the place
we misplace it by
falling in love with that one person we
can't have and then that person receives
a projection of a a
a numenon
an expression of the divinity and then
achievable nominal and it
attains an aura of impossible
transcendence of
impossible value and that's the
religious intuition in us being
projected outwards what we see is what
is in us not on the person the person is
just receiving that projection or in
transhumanism
i don't know whether you know anything
about humanism
it's a religious movement
it's outwardly religious it's the idea
that
there will be a god we will build it we
will construct a computer that will be
capable of producing a better version of
itself and that one an even better
version of itself and so on and so forth
until
god and god is made of silicon and it
will i need to find a way to help us
live forever through drugs and surgery
and and finding new laws of physics and
we will bring back the dead by uploading
all information about that person into
some kind of artificial neural network
ray kurzweil he wants to have his dad
back
his dad he's a kid who lost his dad
young so was i i was 12 lost my dad
he never found a way to
integrate that experience
and operate the alchemical
work on it and transmute it into
something else he's still trying to
bring back his dad yeah this this is
religion through and through
yeah but it's a it's a it's a very
strange materialistic and uh distorted
religion that's for sure
i i wonder if you've one of the
one of the the things that interests me
is
the the notion of
this hierarchy of of beings i don't know
if you if you have dealt with that at
all i've
i've been thinking about dante quite a
bit in terms of let's say what you're
saying the way that the comedian seems
to be structured in part
is through the capacity for
smaller loves to exist in in larger
loves and that this is really an image
of of reality so dante starts with uh
let's say poetry
and poetry is what
awakens the possibility of love you know
moving to beatrice then moving up uh to
uh to bernard of clairvaux uh and then
ultimately to the virgin ultimate to
christ and then up into you know the the
transcendent unity of all things um and
so i guess my my question is
have you thought about that as well like
the web the man in which certain
intelligences act as
principalities for other intelligences
the idea of gods or patron saints like
how we can draw others into into to to
being
do you see that as a hidden hierarchy
behind the world in some sense
i see it i mean i really do see it just
as
the way that things work that is that
the way that we
there's there's the personal aspect
which is that
the little loves those even like
having a good drink having a smoke or
something which could actually become
addictive or sex all of these go all of
these things can be goods if they are
embedded in higher goods and they are
ultimately embedded in something like
virtue something like worship something
which leads you up it really is a way to
preserve the notion that all existence
has the possibility of being good but
then that also works in terms of
let's say beings themselves so in myself
i experienced that hierarchy of goods
and in the world there's a there's a
hierarchy of goods and there's a
hierarchy of beings which hold other
beings together a simple way to to think
about it is of course you know like how
a country works how you have a president
and you have you have different beings
that hold to hold that together but that
this could go much further than just a
physical
just the way we see it in the world
something we can see but that can
work all the way all the way up to
something like patron saints or gods or
angels or virtues that actually exist
and hold aspects of reality together
you mean more by this than just
supervenins like
we can speak about the mind of china
but it merely supervenes on the
minds of china's citizens
in other words there isn't really a mind
that corresponds to china in an
ontological sense
it's just a way of speaking about the
collective dynamics of the interactions
between chinese citizens but you mean
more than this you mean something that
has an ontological reality well the
reason why i mean more than that is that
the let's say the phrase that you just
used to talk about china i could use to
talk about myself or about you that is
that you know jonathan doesn't really
exist he's just an image that we have to
account for the interactive aspects of
my psyche uh and so that are not and
then you could keep going lower and
lower and you can say that about every
constitutive aspect of reality
so once i notice that fractally i can
apply that type of argumentation to
myself or to human beings
then i
see less of a problem to then apply it
up towards the the ontological reality
of of higher beings
if
in in under
sorry in other circumstances sometimes
another language creeps into my mind
in other
circumstances i would normally be
cautious about this because
normally i speak from
reason and objective evidence
so if there is some
structure in nature i would look for its
physical correlates in other words how
that structure manifests itself to mine
empirical observation and if i cannot
find
that
empirical
manifestation of it then i would say
we would need to have very good
conceptual reasons to infer that that
thing exists in the absence of any
direct
empirical way to to verify that it's
there
so i would normally be very cautious i
would say
um
dissociation in humans
show us that our own otherwise unified
mind can't fragment itself and it's
fragmenting itself all the time
when you dream you identify with your
dream avatar not with the rest of the
dream but guess what the rest of the
dream is you as well you're just
dissociate dissociated from a part of
yourself until you wake up or when you
forget things or when you
compartmentalize things in order to
remain functional which is a deliberate
form of dissociation
um so we can speak of that
but it's more difficult to go the other
way and say there is a bigger mind
that that we could call
the hierarchies of heaven
the angels and archangels and the saints
and so forth
because we do not have
well at least we think right now we do
not have a direct physical correlate of
that
of course there are people who would
deny that you talk about dante
dante would deny that because he talked
about the love that moves the sun and
the other stars in other words
maybe the stars are
the empirical physical expressions of
some higher level
form of mentation that also is
circumscribed by some form of
dissociative boundary and has an
individual identity perhaps but
in the early 21st century it's very
difficult to go down these avenues of
speculation
because
how do you differentiate that from
the aliens from the pleiades sending us
heart vibrations you see what i mean
no
well i i i think it's not it's not that
hard to differentiate in the sense that
um
so i i i'm a big fan of sam maximus the
confessor and
in his
it's in his vision the human being is in
a way the laboratory of meaning it's
it's that in the in the human
that
even the higher principalities are
gathered in a certain manner it's it's
difficult to fully
uh
it's difficult it's it's not super
precise the way that he talks about it
but he has a sense in which in a certain
manner man is above the angels and so
you can understand that you see christ
represented as a man when he's creating
the world and so there's an idea adam
kadman which which is there in philo of
alexandria but appears rather in the
idea of a in iconography we see it very
clearly the notion that man is at the
outset
that the
universal man is at the beginning of all
things um and so
these intelligences so a good example
would be
right jung jung did something similar
where he said so the star it's not that
the stars are legislating our experience
is that we project meaning into this
into this infinite tapestry of
possibility and now that pattern has a
certain form of reality because it
corresponds to our
our psyche into our psychic projection
and so we the it's like you could say
that there are no patterns in the stars
because there's a there's millions and
millions of them and the patterns we
trace are just projections of our psyche
but there might be a way in which
if the pattern of our psyche is
the laboratory of how reality comes
together and we it's hard to avoid that
because we are the people looking at the
world then those patterns can also have
causal
effect
i uh uh i'll be more it's not the big
ball of gas that's when we say so it's
not the big ball of gas but it's the
pattern of the heavens which is causally
affecting the world through
if you want to see it as through the
projection of the human psyche into that
of objective patterns that that have
developed from millennia or millennia it
doesn't matter but it can still have a
causal effect
i i
i don't reject this at all
um
recent studies are showing again and
again
that the universe at its largest scales
which we can simulate you know we can't
image it because we are within it but we
can compute it
and the structure of the universe the
network structure and topology of the
universe at its largest scales is
mind-bogglingly similar to the structure
of organic nervous systems
and there is no known reason why this
should be the case to call it a cosmic
coincidence would be the understatement
of history of all history
because the correspondence
is
rather precise
so
it suggests the fractality of minds and
its manifestations so the universe as a
whole looks like a nervous system
because it too is the body of the divine
mind in other words it's the extrinsic
appearance of the divine mind and the
whole thing operates through hierarchies
of self self-similarity or or or fractal
hierarchies so to say
religious iconography suggests that and
i take religious iconography seriously
there is an icon from the ukrainian
orthodox church with
the church fathers gathered in a
conference underneath two large
mountains
so you see that you know those
individuals are within the earth
which suggests that what we
call the physical world is actually the
outer appearance of a hierarchy of being
i do take that seriously
and i do take introspection seriously
and i'll be very open with you um
at this point in my life i will i'm 47 i
will be 48 this year
it's
trivial for me it has become trivial for
me to
notice the movements of the impersonal
within
me i know what is my own [ __ ] and i know
it's not if you know what i mean yeah um
when i was 30 it would have been
impossible to make that distinction
because you you just don't have
the subtlety of inner perception to make
these differentiations
so you were all the time deceiving
yourself your ego is all the time
pretending to be something higher and
noble and driving your actions well in
fact it's all of your [ __ ] all of
your wish fulfillment your search for
meaning it's all that superficial stuff
it's all you
um
but
if you get beaten up by life enough over
the decades
and you are paying attention which most
people don't i happen to be put together
in a way that i cannot help but pay
attention and i have paid attention
uh for the best part of 40 years
and now i think maybe i'm deluding
myself still but i don't think so i
think i can notice the impersonal in me
but that impersonal
is not oceanic consciousness either
that impersonal
has an agenda
it's not mine but it's not the whole of
the universe either
it's an individual agenda of some form i
i i personalize it and i call it the
diamond
because it gives me some guardian angel
is good enough
well i i
it's okay i'm just
watching you no i'll tell you why i
don't use that yeah my diamond is
morally neutral
um
and if i'm not careful with i mean my
diamond doesn't give a damn whether i
will have a roof over my head tomorrow
food on the plate
it doesn't give a [ __ ] sorry doesn't
give a damn about it at all um
because it's impersonal its agenda is
not my
individual survival as a tool of nature
as an expression of a part of nature
um it's not operating at the level of
comfort and survival
uh it's it's it's a force of nature
it's like the tornado that comes
destroys your house and kills your
family did it have a bad intention to do
that of course not the tornado is not
living in this
frame framework of
you know survival and comfort so the
diamond is a force of nature and as a
force of nature i
i perceive it as very
morally ambiguous
or neutral
it knows where it wants to go
and it will beat me up to
to help it go in that direction
but it's it doesn't have my individual
well-being in mind if you know what i
what i mean my well-being is something
that i negotiate with it
literally i negotiate with it
every day so i don't call it the
guardian angel
so what would what would its its telos
be or can you recognize that
oh yeah
yeah it uh
if you think you recognized it right and
then you go down the path suggested by
that misapprehension
uh it gives you very quick feedback
that you're you're pursuing the wrong
path that was not it already all right
it it turns my mental inner life into
sheer hell
all kinds of things will plague me
unexplainable anxieties obsessions
physical symptoms
it
it i don't want to use
certain words that
that informally i would but
it's a show
it's a very bad show that happens within
so it gets to a point where it's
inevitable to learn to recognize what
its agenda is so i do i do recognize it
and that's why i do what i'm doing now
i've
two years ago jonathan
i abandoned
a 25 year long career in the high-tech
corporate world
if i had stayed
i probably would
be close to what you would call rich
um
i and it's not only the money it's
my social network my sense of identity
my sense of
value and differentiation
uh i i i left it kicking and screaming
because my diamond was very clear about
what i had to do
and what i had to do part of it is
talking to you today and and leading
essentia foundation
um i negotiated enough with it that i
delayed the process until i could secure
myself more or less
it does have an agenda yeah
very impersonal
so that suggests to me there is indeed a
hierarchy of dissociation in the divine
mind
because my diamond comes across to me as
something that's not human
but it's not the whole of the divine
mind either it is an aspect of it
yeah
um
saint gregory nissa talks about in the
the life of moses
he he uses moses and aaron as an analogy
to talk about this he calls it he calls
it the helper
he has the notion that there's moses and
then there's his helper
and he he
he differentiates two sides of the
helper and what he comes to is actually
the little cartoon image of the angel on
the right shoulder and the devil on the
left shoulder you know and and saint
gregory actually describes exactly that
and so he he separates aaron the helper
into two
that is it's something like
it's a good way to understand it's like
a transpersonal
uh
a transpersonal pull towards something
and so it can it can it's something
which is beyond you which is pulling you
in a direction
uh
but he sees it as either going up or
going down so it's like you have certain
a certain transpersonal aspect of you
which is pulling you down towards these
little these little circles of attention
and this this kind of chaotic levels of
attention and you have one
an aspect of this helper which is
pulling which is whispering to you and
kind of pulling you up towards higher
levels of attention i use of course
gregory doesn't use the word attention
i'm using that here because it makes
sense to what we're talking about uh and
so it's so you can see it in iconography
you've probably seen these images if you
know orthodox iconography a little bit
you know the angel pulling up the uh you
know the toll houses and then the the
devil kind of pulling uh someone down
towards hell this is this this kind of
image of how we have
how we are embedded in this
transpersonal mind you could say
that the push and pull exists it's um
introspectively very clear to me
it's a it's a
a datum of existence
it's it's not something that is open to
theoretical speculation if you know what
i mean it's there
um
i don't
divide the diamond into one good and one
bad i tend to identify with the bad
like
the bad one is me it's bernardo
it's the guy that's probably the best
way to do it actually if too
in terms of uh in terms of
transformation it's probably the best
way to do it but it's not really a
choice it's how i feel it and yeah
bernardo is the guy who is
looking to secure his own comfort and
safety and the comfort and safety of the
other little beings that bernardo cares
about like bernardo's girlfriend and
bernardo's cats and bernardo's friends
and
he wants to have a little bit of power a
little bit of money and
get some recognition
you know and then and that's me
that's that's the ego
and the other pull
that's from the impersonal that's not me
but it's neither good or bad it's
neither an angel or a devil it it's
morally
ambiguous again it's a force of nature
that's how i experience it but talking
to other philosophers and reading
history
i i and that's part of the reason why i
sort of granted that there are reasons
to think of a hierarchy of being
other people other philosophers seem to
have other diamonds like socrates
diamond would only tell him what not to
do
would never tell him where to go
only tell him when socrates was doing
something wrong then the diamond would
say no
my diamond is not like that
my diamonds just kicked me in the butt
in a certain direction you go there you
bastard here boom
go
and i go kiki and screaming that's not
socrates diamond it's another diamond
and some people have a seductive diamond
a diamond that seduces
from the front
instead of a diamond that kicks you from
the back that's not my diamond
and
and and i envy other people's diamonds
um
i think in the cosmic lottery
no no i'm not going to say what i was
going to say because
my diamond has brought tremendous
meaning to my life despite
all the suffering and all this stuff
so i'm not going to spit on it
but
there is nothing romantic about the
diamond
if you know what i mean yeah there is
something romantic oh we have a guardian
angel oh you go out mushy and it's so
romantic there is nothing romantic about
my diamond nothing serious
yeah i don't see anything romantic in
the guardian angel myself they're also
they're often represented as warriors
anyways it's not particularly uh it's
not true i like it yeah
but so my so let's say the way that i
let's how can i
how can i phrase this and so the way
that i like to think about it
so the the diamond what your diamond one
of the things it's asking for you is is
let's say direction and attention that
is
you have to look in its direction and
attend to
and that is how it kind of pulls you or
pushes you or kicks you whatever in the
direction that you're going and so the
way that i like to think of of
transpersonal beings is similar that is
when we talked about for example the
existence of the angel of china would be
a good way to think about it it's that
what the angel of china is asking of the
chinese is to attend to it
that's the first thing it's asking and
so by by the multiple attending to the
one that is how it finds body in the
world
and so that is how it kind of it manages
the body and so you can
apply that fractionally
at all levels and you can understand
that there's something about that which
is which is right you can even think
about your own cells without using the
same level of attention but that you
know the cells that attend to the telos
of my body they're the ones which will
make my body
exist and go forward and the cells that
don't will be fought by those other
cells that that are
that are in line with the the the the
attention
of my body um and so i think that when
you notice that a country also works
that way or that hire a basketball team
or anything that in which multiple
individuals attend towards the but do
you see these
these hierarchies as supervening
on us in other words as just emergent
phenomena from us or do you see them as
pre-existing like there is a
pre-existing angel of china
well you could say something like the
way that i would say it would be that
that all all exists pre-exist in
eternally in the divine mind that is in
to the extent that mind does not is not
unfolded in time then
all the aspects of mind exist in it from
you know and then they unfold through
what we call time and what we call space
and so the being you know the angel of
china eternally exists in the mind of
god and then unfolds in its time and in
its space the way that any being unfolds
in their time in their space so you
could you could you if you wanted to say
that it
like it doesn't exist before
before china then i would say that's
fine it doesn't bother me that much but
i think there's a way to
i would say
i i the way i always do it is i ask
myself that of myself is that
do i
exist or am i just an emergent phenomena
of particles and thoughts and you could
say well yeah i'm that but i also think
that i have a me or i have a
a a consciousness with super veins on
the multiplicity of my
of my being it's not a hundred percent
it's not something which is completely
sealed shut and totally uh uh let's say
that that's completely authoritarian but
it's nonetheless exists and so in that
sense i also think that china exists and
that
families exist and that there's an
there's myriads of angels the way that
you know that the
the thomas would have said
but if china tomorrow
i mean we know historically that given
enough time all nations will cease to
exist at least in their former form
if china tomorrow ceases to exist or a
few
decades from now cease to exist
does
that level of the hierarchy continue to
exist does the angel of china survive
china does the angel of jonathan survive
jonathan
you well
a good way to say it would be something
like it exists in the eschaton
but it exists in the totality of all
things within the divine mind it doesn't
it it can continue to linger to have a
lingering uh existence without without
um
without a localized body so for example
i think that if we say that greece
doesn't exist anymore i would say that
that's that's malarkey like the greece
still exists today and you know we carry
babylon we carry all these things so
there is there is a certain manner in
which these bodies continue to although
weaken continue to to exist and be
assimilated into
into other beings uh
and so that's the way that i see it and
it's also
these beings are they fit into each
other it's not like um
how can i say that
i don't think any being has a discrete
existence it always exists in a fractal
relationship with other beings within
higher beings and so
so the the
the the notion that that
certain so in the same way so a good
example would be that
these beings are being held by higher
beings and so if the they say the angel
of all nations right or christ himself
holds authority over all the angels
and
and that is how it works in the same way
that if my cells come and go in my body
you know you could say well does that
cell still exist well no but you know
it's it's held together in potential you
know in in the actuality of the higher
being so that's the way that i tend to
think about it i don't know if it makes
sense this is becoming a little more
esoteric here
analytically it's very difficult to
unambiguously conceptualize what you're
saying yeah without internal
contradiction
pen psychists tried to do exactly that
and it's very very difficult
some would say impossible
but i i do feel
the smell of what you're trying to say
your dream avatar there is a sense in
which your dream avatar dies the moment
you wake up
but there is a sense in which your dream
avatar also survives in your memory
so in that sense everything that has
ever existed survives as an eternal
memory in the divine mind yeah
and but then you
you solved the problem in one way going
forward but you didn't solve the problem
the other way going backwards like
did the angel of china pre-exist china
and it
provided a template for the formation of
china
did it exist as an archetype in the
sense that like jung said that
the matrix structure of a diamond
pre-exists the diamond because it's
encoded in in the laws of nature
so that would be a sense in which things
could pre-exist
without pre-existing as particular
manifestations of the thing that
pre-exists
but it gets into
very difficult territory analytically
this is something that is better grasped
intuitively i think
maybe that's maybe i just grasp it
intuitively so i don't i don't feel i
have to analytically but but let's
explore that i mean i think that that
it's a good idea to to explore it and so
if we understand china as a as a as a
species of something like
human communities
right and so
you could ask that question that you're
asking about any level of speciation of
different beings and so you have uh so
the question is like do rottweilers
how do rottweilers exist within the
speciation of dogs like how do
identities exist within higher
identities and i think that if if we are
able to resolve that problem at the
level of the dog where we understand
that this that multiplicity is held in
unity and multiplicity is to a certain
extent indefinite
but the multiplicity that's held in the
unity is indefinite
so you could say that the the the
identities
that the identities that dog can give
are indefinite there's an indefinite
amount of dogs possible speciations of
dogs
right but they still nonetheless are
held together
by the dog speciation and so i think
that if we think about it that way then
the problem of the angels of countries
is less complicated because we have we
have the divine logos
which manifests the bond of love of all
of all possible things
in in
in the highest aspect and then that
speciation lower down is and then lower
from from countries or lower from
countries you have families you have
groups you have
associations you have all kinds of
things which are just
possible speciations that are held
together up into higher identity
like i'm really i get you can see i'm
more of a platonist like at this point
but but i don't know if that if that
does that analytically does that make
sense or like in the way that you see it
i see it in a way that makes sense
analytically it's very difficult and the
reason it's difficult analytically when
i say analytically i mean
to make it fully explicit and
unambiguous is very difficult and the
reason is
it entails determining where boundaries
lie
where are the boundaries of identity
hierarchical or otherwise where do they
lie so if you talk about the identity of
china
is there the identity of hong kong
yeah i think so is there the identity of
shanghai versus beijing
if the table has an identity and i pull
a leg off the table does the leg now
have its own identity
and if i nail it back to the table did
it lose its own identity
does the mountain have an identity and
if so when a boater deglues from the
mountain mountain and comes bouncing
down the slope
is it not does it not now have its own
identity when it's flying and does it
reconnect the mounting every time it
touches the mounting as it rolls down
it becomes arbitrary because there are
infinite possible boundaries and if one
doesn't have a
some kind of explicit and unambiguous
criteria for determining identity
boundaries lie here
then it's a free-for-all because you can
put boundaries anywhere and then it's an
explosion of identities
so i don't mind the explosion of
identities that is i think that there is
an indefinite amount of possible
identity so that doesn't bother me and i
think that if we understand it as a
hierarchy then the the boulder can exist
in the mountain
and and it doesn't prevent the mountain
from existing we can recognize lower
level identities within so like the
table is a good example so does the tape
does the leg of the table have an
identity the answer is yes it does well
actually it had an identity
like while it was still nailed to the
table and if you remove it from the the
the table i can still recognize it as a
leg of a chair of a tape
but we were talking about the identity
augmentation in the sense that there is
something it is like to be the leg of
the table as opposed to the table as a
whole of course we can
define boundaries on the screen of
perception but that's not what we were
talking about we were talking about
uh individual individuated minds
so the
if the mountain has one individuated
mind like i have an individuated mind
when the boater
rolls down the slope and becomes
separated from the mountain does the
boater now acquire its own private mind
as distinct from the private mind of of
of the mountain and there is a
philosophical sense in which if you say
that there are infinite
uh
mental identities in this sense uh
entities with private uh inner minds if
you say there are infinite ones of those
it's exactly the same thing as to say
that there are none yeah
no i don't i the way that the way that i
the way that i see it is i see it really
the in the manner that i talked about
saint max was before is that i see them
gathered into my mind
and so i
to the extent in which they have their
own individual
uh like discrete existence
in a certain extent is an extension of
of man as when i say man i mean
right the incarnate man as the image of
of mind let's say or the highest image
or the most gathered image of mind that
we that we have because it's also that
through our conscious experience that we
have it and so that's the way that i
that i tend to see it uh i don't know if
that resolves the conflict that it does
it does because what you're saying is
that within our private minds which we
know exists even if they are illusions
they still exist as illusions something
is making this illusion happen
um maybe there could have been no
illusion but there is one so there is
some kind of mechanism within the
context of our private minds which are
there
we experience fractal reflections
of all the identities in nature
that
i agree with that completely okay
because i think
the subjectivity in me is the same as
the subjectivity new and it's the same
as the subjectivity of the universal
mind or the divine mind like who who
said it
uh that the eyes with which god sees me
are the same eyes with which i see god
was it a no it was not um
who one of the creatures like is it a
christian sound like a sufi to me not a
christian mystic uh was it eckhart i
think it was actually yeah that could be
eckhart yeah that could definitely be
possibly and
and if you grasp this
and it's very difficult to put it in
sort of unambiguous analytical terms we
we don't have the conceptual armor to do
this but if you grasp this
that the eyes through which you look for
god
are the eyes of god looking for itself
if you
if you feel it in your being not only
conceptually as a thought but as
as an experience you're directly
acquainted with
then it becomes very obvious that all
singing identities exist within you as
experiences
as a reflection of the macrocosm in in
the microcosm
it's
yeah i mean i i can't defend it
analytically
i can't write a paper yeah or the
journal of consciousness studies
defending this but if you ask me do i
believe this
i i know this
it's a it's a
living experience for me so i have a
diamond uh jonathan i i don't want to
change the subjects if you want to
pursue this a little further but i had
this question
i mean go for it i don't mark if you
want to turn jacks we kind of we kind of
uh we're just going at it here so i
don't know if you had things you wanted
to to talk about and deal with you so i
um had thought about going in the
direction actually of
a recent essay about paul king's north
and um
talking about all the different myths of
progress and using that as a kind of
contrast to serve for clarity
with what you guys are speaking about
but if you want to go with the diamond
let's play with me too very quickly i
just i just wondered if jonathan
has a diamond
[Music]
i don't i don't experience it in the
same way that that that you experience
it i i think that i
i tend to experience it more in the way
that saint gregory talks about it that
is that i i sense that there's a
transpersonal aspect of me
like i sense on the one hand something
like what saint paul says right i do the
things that i do not want to do i
experience that all the time right where
i'm doing i find myself lying and
there's another voice in my head going
why why are you doing this like why are
you lying or like why are you why are
you acting this way why are you taking
the credit or whatever it is that i'm
doing that's this and so i i experienced
this this
this kind of force that's pulling me
down uh and then i also on this in the
same way
have
a sense that
um
something like a good christian way of
saying it would be like i know i feel a
calling
is a good christian way of saying it i
feel like i have this calling and that
i'm being
like you said i'm being kind of pulled
forward towards certain things
both in my own life in terms of
of transformation but also even like you
said professionally in terms of the
types of things i'm supposed to pay
attention to the types of things i'm
supposed to put my energy into and if i
don't
listen to that voice and i suffer
greatly and if i if i listen to that
voice i suffer
but the suffering is worth it like it's
worth it for what it gives and so that's
the way that i tend to experience it
it's exactly the same for me
you don't personalize it as i do
probably because you have always done
the diamonds bidding so you you
you don't have a background to contrast
it with
you but i also see it but i think
i think that i see
that let's say something like my
guardian angel i tend to see through the
guardian angel
into christ
into the the incarnate god and so so
it's not that i it's like if that's that
maybe even be just my protestant
background because i used to be
protestant where it's like i even even
if i when i feel pulled i tend to want
to see through that towards
something else like so you'll hear
people i think that
the experience you have you'll hear
christians say something like that all
the time we'll say like god
showed me this for god and it's not god
directly it's it is this intermediary
being but i understand too why because
it's pulling you up and it's pulling you
into more being then it's easy you want
to see through it and see see the the
higher aspect kind of pulling you
forward so that's that's how i tend to
but i have other beings pulling at me
all the time like my patrons i have
certain saints which have imposed
themselves on me
uh some like saint maximus who i've
chosen but other saints
like saint like saint christopher for
example who really has imposed himself
on me and uh and is is there to to and
he's kind of pulling me
uh pulling me in certain directions and
i yeah and i i can't deny it yeah you
always describe it as pulling never as
pushing yeah
i think it's
somebody who who feels pushed like i do
it like i yeah i won the lottery the
other way around
um
but what you described i i recognize and
there is the diamond which which unlike
you i don't see it as a as the summon
bonum i don't see it
as a
morally positive force i see it as a
very morally ambiguous force
who doesn't care much about my
comfort or safety
but i also feel the push of the
ancestors instead of the saints
like i feel the push
to
sort of
clear the record of the ancestors and
hear the record of jung clear the record
of schopenhauer and the one that's
really pushing me now
wants his record clear i mean it could
all be fantasies of my mind of course
somewhat impersonal but uh it's useful
for me to attach names
to these things because it enables a
a relationship with them i feel the push
of um
nicolas von kuz nikolai de kuza kuzanus
i don't know whether you
know about him a
hardly known philosopher who was also a
bishop
of the church in the 15th century
and i feel
the push of that image now like
clear his record you know
vindicate him
um
um
because he left the treasure buried in
the feud and nobody has a map and we
need to find that and open it up
so that i feel too it's less
personalized than than the diamond the
diamond is just overwhelming with me
totally overwhelmed me
and i
it's a very present reality for me
because i used to not listen to it
so i i know what it is like to ignore
the presence of the diamond and and
therefore its presence now is
has great contrast contrast against that
previous background in which i thought
it's just me i'm the master of my own
house and i remember that and it
provides a background that really
highlights the diamond now like oh there
is that that thing there
that i used to ignore and not listen to
and pretend that it didn't exist
but it was always there and it's very
distinct
[Music]
so mark go ahead with your
what you talked that you wanted us i
didn't read paul king norris last essay
but maybe you can i usually do read all
his essays i just haven't gotten to that
one yet no that's great and sorry we're
taking a lot of notes about it so i can
try and freeze it in a way that i hope
sort of lines with you guys and see if
we can use that as a spring word so um i
wanted to phrase it within the context
of the kind of meaning crisis there's no
use for the mark jonathan which i think
in line with what you guys have said is
two things in particular
behind that even if it might phrase it
that way a crisis of authority and which
authority or authorities are we to trust
i suppose and a direction
with the kind of myth of progress that
he describes having no direction there's
no destination clear in mind whereas
from the christian context suppose you
have the kingdom of god however hard
that might be to define and this kind of
general crisis of modernity so um
paul's recent work i think might help us
find some convergence in clarifying some
key trends and problems i think he picks
up in some ways where alan watts left
off which i know bernardo likes and from
a christian perspective i think even
nikolai berdayev serving this kind of
prophetic role so
i wanted to speak about uh
this notion of progress that he
critiques in his article
a it's he suggests a number of things
that progress once at the end of history
it wants the end of transcendence and so
on and he mentions how modernity
actually makes a major break by
following fully sort of developing the
anthropological theme so the
transcendence is pictured as beyond is
replaced by this kind of transcendence
within the world
and he says the transcendence within the
world can be translated as progress with
no ultimate truth or higher story
there's nothing to stop us can abandon
the universe to our desires indeed to do
so was our duty and this in august of
the nazis telling them
is what explained actually 20th century
history having replaced religion with
this kind of
a perverse philosophy we then tried
putting philosophy into practice on a
kind of grand scale with terrible
results so then he goes on or progress
once is the death of god so supposedly
considering all that
how do you hope in humility then to help
address this crisis with your work and a
i've been thinking about that uh from
both your perspectives then
i'm gonna go first there bernardo oh um
two thousand years of preaching have not
solved the problem
so
we know at least a few things that don't
work
um
pure philosophy has not solved the
problem
otherwise
you know all the philosophers
that
you know
occupy the path the long path before us
would have made a significant difference
in the way these things have evolved
i tend to think
that the collective mind of humanity and
we can think of it as a you know
danger of humanity in jonathan's
language um
it
as as
people in in religious circles say the
spirit will move the way it moves the
angel of humanity
will stir and move the way it does
i think the only thing we can do
is
to put some beacons here and there
so even when
that great
angel of humanity
looks around
for for some bearings
that it will find the beacons
we cannot make it look we cannot
convince it to look
we cannot make it go in the direction of
the beacons
all we can do is
place the beacon there light it up
if it does happen to look and find and
does happen to want to come in that
direction then we've done our part
but it's not a process that
that can be forced
it's it's
too big of a giant to be corralled in a
certain direction by mere human minds
and human actions
or by preaching or even
tremendously compelling philosophical
reasoning
it will not make it happen
all it can do is
plant the beacons around
and hope for the best and cross our
fingers
and to me there is freedom in the
recognition
of this small part that i'm supposed to
to play
because
it doesn't make me feel a sense of
responsibility for the final outcome
because if you do feel a sense of
responsibility for the final outcome
you are lost in a very dark space and
you may react to it through
inflation
like hitler taking responsibility for
the final outcome of the destiny of the
german peoples
that's what you get
you get this kind of
tremendously dysfunctional pathological
inflation that can lead to disaster
and if you don't get that inflation then
you feel like you're nothing you feel
powerless
before a a
tremendously powerful universe
that doesn't even know you exist and
might as well step on you by just not
noticing that you are there like we
step on an end
which is also not a good place to be i
think freedom resides in service which
is something that we in the west knew
but have forgotten
um and it's it's a it's a seeming
paradox
because when you serve it's like
there is a canosis involved you're
losing yourself because you're serving
something that isn't you
your life is no longer about you
you are just
a tool
a small tool
um so there is this sense in which you
sort of extinguish yourself in service
so how can you be free
well you can be free
from
the claus claustrophobia
of purely personal meaning
because
you see even if you achieve everything
you want ultimately it's all for nothing
you're just a person you will be
forgotten 100 years from now if you're
extremely famous a thousand years from
now 10 000 years from now you'll be
forgotten it will all be for nothing if
you think that it's about you
it's extremely claustrophobic and it's a
prison it's the prison of the
significance of the personal self that's
what happens if you think your life's
about you
but when you
extinguish yourself in service
wow it's like opening the windows you
know it's like looking at the horizon
everything becomes huge the moment you
disappear
the moment
and how do we explain this i've been
trying to explain this the past year or
so and to fail every single time
to me
setting up that little beacon without
any control of the process
is my freedom
it's the insignificance of setting up
the beacon that is my freedom
i lose myself in it
yeah i don't know whether i can say this
any better maybe jonathan as an artist
would do no but i think better than i do
i think that you're really you're really
coming right up to this mystery about
how multiplicity and unity exist
it's really in a manner the surprise of
what christianity in my vision the
surprise of what christianity offers but
i think you see that in other traditions
as well but you definitely see it in
christianity which is like okay so why
is the cross
like this cross thing like what do we do
with this like
what is this what is this cross thing at
the top of the mountain why is that the
thing we're asked to pay attention to
and that it's the realization that
it is in giving yourself
to
a higher being
that you're you lose yourself and then
you're full you you you find yourself
filled and so
i think that that's what you're that's
what you're experiencing and i and i
think that that's actually how things
work like that's actually how the world
works is that that fractally things give
themselves sacrifice themselves
for their higher participation and and i
think that even the ritual sacrifices
were ritualized versions
of that like we take something precious
we give it up
and then we receive fullness from above
and i think now in in terms of
christianity now we talk about this the
word the sacrifice of worship the
sacrifice of attention so as you attend
to the higher and you give yourself then
you are you're filled you're filled by
that higher participation that can of
course can become pathological
and it and we've seen many examples in
which it has but it's nonetheless the
way that things work
um and i i tend to agree with with
bernardo in the sense that i i see that
there are certain patterns which are
playing themselves out which we're not
gonna we're not gonna stop at this point
we're not gonna stop
this this pattern and
um
there are stories from the past which
tell us about these moments you know and
there are versions of
of uh i've i made a video on the book of
enoch recently where
the description
of the
the
of intermediary beings towards power and
towards desire and towards it's kind of
like taking these
these patterns from above and then you
know
incarnating them and these giants that
then devour the world i think that
that's where we are like we're really
you know when saint peter says like in
the time of noah i think that that's
pretty much where we are and so the only
thing we can do is build an ark you know
and and and i think that when when
bernardo talks about beacons i think
that that's something like that
and we and the other thing we can do
is understand that
the world exists ultimately in in a
certain way
and i think that it exists through these
these these types of principalities and
so when you know
when we hear this idea you know acquire
the spirit of peace and you will and
millions around thousands around you
will be saved i think that that's also
something which we can do which is that
to to become
more
and in becoming more you
you somehow pull others in
into the ark it's the only way to say i
don't know how to say is that in
becoming more in working out your own
crap in in kind of consolidating what's
immediately around you your life your
family your friendships your
relationship to to to the people around
you and
encountering that in a manner which is
true through the the spirit of service
that bernardo talked about i think that
that actually has more
that has more effects than we think that
it does and it it actually acts as
little
little beacons little arcs of
possibility that will rise up after the
after the fire um
but i think that in terms of the big
pattern i i don't i don't see
it seems like things are accelerating in
ways that are
are you know we could barely have
predicted
we could have
intuited but now we're seeing it things
are really accelerating um and this idea
of progress you know right now we have
people in davos you know you know
planning the future talking about how
we're going to have
we're going to have all these you know
we're going to use all these different
technologies to make us more whatever
that means and
that's exactly the problem that paul is
paul king's north is is talking about
where
it's a it's an
it's not a recent thing right i mean
nietzsche was the first one to identify
exactly this and to go through the
consequences of this in the microcosm of
his own life because
there was someone
with a profound religious disposition
nietzsche a profound religious
disposition
who
thought his way out of religion by
interpreting religion literally
and
building a straw man for religion then
setting it alight
burning it up
so
where
would that man
put his religious intuition
the the fountainhead of meaning that
that was active within him where was he
going to put that
he put that in the superman in the uber
mage yeah which was his way to sort of
pull transcendence downwards
and squeeze it into a physical entity of
some form that he called the secular
ubermensch
the the man that
transcends himself
and and what is peculiar is that if you
read nietzsche's work he never says what
the superman is
yeah there there is one passage in which
he characterizes it indirectly like it
talks about
man
being the intermediary step between the
ape and the superman but he never says
here's what the superman is he doesn't
define the bloody thing
it is the central pillar of his late
work and he doesn't define it
and he goes mad
that's how he ends his days 11 years of
madness mental illness
and i think that microcosm that what
played in the microcosm of nietzsche is
what is playing the macrocosm of
humanity
a hundred
and fifty years later
um
i just hope we don't go mad
when we realize that we are failing to
pull transcendence downwards and try to
make it palpable it's not in the nature
of the thing to be that
it is us who have to transcend ourselves
it doesn't make sense to put
transcendence into us
it's like pulling the word the world
into the prison
no it's not gonna happen you cannot pull
the world into your prison cell all you
can do is
break out
it's not going to work the other way
around it didn't work for nietzsche
it's not going to work for us
yeah i think that if nietzsche knew that
the that the ubermensch would be furries
in the metaverse i i think he might have
he might have changed his mind
okay
in agreement with what you described
there bernardo a dr wayne gashado an
australian philosopher he describes
nature as an ideas retex
but maybe butcher what he says but takes
the his little idea makes it the the
reality is replacing the reality for the
map and um falls into the same chapter
of the people that he's critiquing and
he sees him in line with
in some ways with plato and a whole host
of philosophers he's got an interest in
history of philosophy but um just strung
into my mind whenever you said that and
i also thought about the way dr ian
mcgill questions kind of framed the
modernity writing about how the left
hemisphere is kind of thinking has come
to dominate so much and um
he mentions that idea that a reason and
it's probably is his fame but
as as the atmosphere is vein was
terrible as a master and i think rabbi
jonathan sex sort of mentions then in
his work similarly in some ways that
science properly understood takes things
apart to see how they work but the
religion so-called brings things
together to see what they mean and which
i think in both of your works they
demonstrate in a more
profound sense than the kind of social
construct of religion is the privatized
level
a
myth that we have going on the west
predominantly i suppose
and
south park says you're going to have a
bad time
so i'd love to to know what are some of
the
ways you think this is manifesting
itself
at societal levels and in line with what
jonathan described as kind of secular
liturgies so i think even down to how we
design our cities for recruiter notions
of things like functionality
and ad ever growing kind of car parks
for our major corporations not that it's
all bad but i wonder about some of the
problems when um
that's our maybe major only emphasis and
there's no center like in the
traditional kind of european cities i
suppose around the church or temples and
things like that elsewhere in the world
would you like to describe that as lose
then going beyond our individual um
selves to cities towns how that abuses
our relationship with the creation then
uh and so i mean i think mark what
you're saying what's interesting
you can kind of see when we talk about
this kind of breakdown and this idea of
progress but how it's actually
manifesting itself in that
you know in a breakdown i think you
pointed to the image of the city is a
great example of of how this works and
so there used to be the way that cities
were understood was almost mythological
i talk about this in um
i talk about this in one of my my
podcast we have this universal history
uh podcast where we talk about how the
founding of cities was even when
constantine founded uh constantinople
there was this scent in which like there
was an angel walking in front of him and
he would walk he was walking with this
standard that he planted at some point
which would mark the limit of the city
and they asked him and he said well i
walked until the angel stopped and then
he he basically planted the city so all
these cities have these mythological uh
foundings and then they end up being
created in a fractal way so the city
itself usually has higher points of
attention and so uh medieval village is
a great example so the church would be
in the center or in something which
represented the center then there would
be the the the steeple would be the
highest building in the church you
weren't allowed actually to build higher
buildings and so it would act as a as a
kind of axis of attention for all the
people in the city
an axis of attention and also a place
that binds you
literally in the sense that you go there
together and you celebrate the things uh
your baptisms marriages all the things
that bind societies at different levels
were celebrated there and then even
during the day right the bells would
ring and then you would do the angelus
or something similar where all people in
the village would turn towards the
center and then would would pray to
participate in the existence of the the
city and so the city itself was
was was
built like a being like was built in a
way in
a the way that you're a microcosm of of
this the same thing right these centers
of attention and the highest thing which
binds all the other aspects of you
together and so right now the way that
we build cities is so completely
utilitarian that we the bare the cities
barely exist except for random
distribution of houses on in space you
know separated by highways and
functional you know uh malls and
functional uh places for entertainment
and this is leading to massive breakdown
in terms of people not knowing their
neighbors people becoming isolated and
ultimately falling into despair and not
even realizing that the very space in
which they live
is participating in their despair with
you know it's not the only thing but
it's definitely fueling the the despair
that they're feeling is living in this
this like amorphous grid of houses you
know on on the landscape
absolutely
i feel it every time i go to the u.s
i i don't have it here because you know
the netherlands is a very small country
all the villages
are old in a sense and there are there
are no i mean there are new
constructions but
they grow in rings around the old
towns and sometimes the old towns merge
together to form a city but every little
neighborhood has that center and that
center has a church
a baker
a pharmacist
the doctor
and a bar yeah in the grocery the
grocery store so it these five or six
things are in every little neighborhood
and it when i go to the u.s
i feel
very ungrounded
because um
you you hardly touch
the ground unless you are indoors
because
you know otherwise you're in a car yeah
from car to indoors yeah that's how it
works yeah you hardly have
pedestrian pathways that you can walk
from one place to the other and people
hop into a car to go
100 meters
for us here it's unthinkable 100 meters
you you don't get into a car
to go 100 meters and uh
and i feel like i'm
i don't know floating in the air there
is no center
the
height is very i have a very strange
feeling in the us
this is one of the big reasons the other
big reason is
television commercials
i find them very alienating
in the u.s i can't relate to them at all
so i can tell you that from an outside
perspective mine what you are saying is
not theory
it's not conjecture
it's a very very
real palpable lived reality
yeah and but it's interesting because i
think that the scandal of america and in
canada we have the same problem
is is leading to a type of consciousness
of of this problem you know and so uh
like i i have a good friend of mine
andrew gould who's an architect and he
is now realizing this and the architects
around him are realizing this and so
they're they're forced to consciously
let's say re-engage with this pattern so
something which let's say in the middle
ages once wasn't thought out it was just
that's how the world works you just do
it and so now we have to i think that
this is true about all the the questions
right now of participation is that we
somehow have like we bit the apple
right we took we took the apple and now
we we can reintegrate the garden but
it's the cross right it's the cross
which will make us reintegrate the
garden it'll be difficult it's going to
be painful uh and ultimately we'll end
with something which is fuller in the
end and i this is maybe like in terms of
the the hope of this whole problem is
that the story seems to be always
something like that like that seems to
be the story of all the stories and so
there's a sense in which possibly the
crisis we're going through although it
is horrible and frustrating that there
is a hope that ultimately the
reintegration which comes after will be
fuller than the one that was before and
that's the that's kind of like the only
hope that i can i can bring when you
read in the book of enoch it's really
it's very powerful because it's talking
about the flood in the book of enoch and
it talks about how all this calamity is
coming because of these
because of the the these uh these demons
these giants that are there and that are
eating the world that are devouring
everything and that are engaged in all
these kind of perverted uh destruction
of the world but then it says that okay
destruction is coming and then after
that god will fill all things you think
interesting like
that this is something describing the
flood but there's a manner in which that
seems to be the
the pattern and even the pattern of
ourselves
bernardo you talked about how someone
who experiences dissociation
and then is able to heal that
dissociation
is maybe more than the person that was
there before yeah
yeah you get a
level higher of insight it's like you
are in a spiral so it feels like you've
come gone back to the same place where
you were before but it's a level higher
as you
go through the spire you're always going
a level higher always coming back to the
beginning but always with a
an understanding of new ones subtlety
and perspective that wasn't there before
even though you're again looking from
that same perspective yeah that's and so
the image
the image of the entire story of the
bible that's the way that i see it and
so we all we often forget that the last
image in scripture the image of the new
jerusalem of the heavenly jerusalem is
the garden of eden it's the tree of life
and the water of life but then around
the tree of life and the water of life
is now this glorious city and so from
from the moment of innocence in the
garden
and then a fall and of the fall bringing
about all these human activities all
this all this kind of human technology
which is constantly leading us into
little levels of distraction and and
thinking that power is going to solve
our problems so all these problems
happen and then ultimately in the end
there's a way in which it gets resolved
in this kind of glorious city where the
the tree is in the center the water is
in the center
the lamb right the self-sacrificial lamb
is in the center but then it it makes
the rest meaningful it fills the rest
with with meaning um so it's at least a
little bit of hope you know that's sweet
let me talk about this
can i run an idea by you it's uh
something i've been thinking about it's
not worked out in my mind but i wonder
what what you would how you would react
to it
uh we were talking about banality
in ritual earlier on when we began this
conversation and i'm totally with you
that we have to
re-ritualize life in order to come back
in contact with its extra dimension of
depth meaning and significance at the
same time and i don't know whether this
is a
dichotomy or a paradox i don't know but
it i also sense that um
the word spirituality is the worst thing
that has ever happened to spirituality
because it made it distinct from reality
yeah
and i sometimes i think that
if we use too romantic language
to talk about
real stuff you know the the bedrock of
existence if we talk about it
in two romantic terms
um we create
a distance between ourselves and it
because we are you know
moist
living beings we go to the loo every day
even kings and it doesn't no good when
that happens and we have to eat stuff
and kill stuff to eat even if you're a
vegetarian you're killing plants to eat
yeah and you know the business of life
is messy there is it's very bloody there
is a lot of suffering
um and it's moist it's warm you know
it's not sleek
marble statue
if you know what i mean yeah no i know
exactly what you mean and and sometimes
i think the romanticized language
creates this in impassable cause
between lived reality and and
and the treasure buried at the end of
the rainbow if you know what i mean
and and we we we do that in language so
is there something to say about
trying to
get a little bit rid of some of
the romanticizing
talking about these things in more
visceral terms yeah
you know
um if we talk about enlightenment i
always go like
what the heck does that even mean
you know this business of enlightenment
what does that even mean
but there is something i know which is
suddenly i became a lot more empathic
and it's a [ __ ] show because i suffer
with the ukrainians i suffer with the
mothers and fathers in texas i suffer
with everybody and it's a horror show
is that what we call enlightenment maybe
maybe that's what it is
you see what i mean yeah yeah but i call
it a [ __ ] show yeah not enlightenment
and and i think there is something to be
said about you know
bringing the language down to our level
a little bit so we can relate to this
stuff as reality and not a romanticized
something that is unachievable either
yeah
no i totally agree and and i
people who watch my videos will hear me
often say something like
go to church uh and and what i'm you
mean by go to church is
yeah that's why i don't talk that's why
go to church is the most boring it
sounds like the most boring thing you
could say to someone but i'm saying go
to church you go to church but it could
be other types of participation you go
to church then it's messy
it's messy because let's say something
like church there are people there that
you would choose to be with and there
are people there that you would not
choose to be with and so all your
buttons will be pressed everything about
you will be challenged you know but
nonetheless so there's something dirty
and moist and and smelly about it but
it's all this dirty moist smelly stuff
which is trying to aim higher and
transform these aspects of reality into
something more and so you kind of get in
my my estimation
through participation in the things that
are immediate to us okay for example
like your family it's like
don't don't talk to me about
enlightenment if you're if you alienated
your kids and you know you hate your
wife and like okay i don't know because
you can see it right you see these kind
of spiritual type people that their
lives are completely in shambles but
they're doing yoga and they're having
mystical experiences like okay exactly
yeah there's something there's something
off about that and so i think that
engagement is probably better you know
and so like so so for example finding a
confessor in the orthodox church like
having someone you have to you go to you
confess to it's
sometimes they'll say the worst thing
like your confessor sometimes will say
the most damaging thing you could ever
hear
but it's like you have to kind of
understand that that's the messiness of
this community right that's the
messiness of this communion as we kind
of move and
kind of move awkwardly you know towards
deification towards towards
transformation um so that's at least the
way that i
try to and i say that but it's like it's
hard for me as much as anybody because
we have all this comfort it's hard for
me as much as anybody to
to to do it but i yeah at least that's
the way that i'm trying to to deal with
that stuff
and so
i'm trying to really pin down what uh
what i'm attempting to say and not
really succeeding yet
that's why symbols are so important but
uh
when i talk about romanticizing
there is a
mushy quality to it
a a kind of perfection to the goal like
the sumo bonum like uh the saint is
purely good and it's all about love and
playing the harp on the clouds
it it's
i don't think
this is a helpful image if you know what
i mean yeah but do you think that that's
really so it's like if you look at the
christian version of that you end up
with like martyrs and saint francis of
assisi like who is poor and like people
who live in the desert and are you know
and so it's like saint mary of egypt
that these are the images of our saints
they're not they're not built on clouds
like you know it's throwing hearts this
is the big one the big one is jesus's
life yeah of course the life of christ
is a big one yeah that's the reality of
the thing that's the reality of service
and and and
in a sort of giving upwards of yourself
um
but if you tell people just go to church
what they think
is
reuben's uh uh
caribees uh uh with you know uh plump
bottoms
playing the high up on clouds and and
it creates this notion
you see what i mean what i'm saying i
know what you mean exactly i totally
understand what you mean this stuff is
real
how do we help people
understand that this stuff is real and
it's so real
it's it's not under their noses it's
behind their noses
it's it's as close as anything can
possibly be it's so close nobody sees it
and and
there's nothing romantic about it
it's tough stuff
yeah
you see what i'm trying to get no i
totally agree you know i think they like
but i think the image of the cross is in
that case
that's that's the best image and helping
people remember
what
what that is but we romanticized even
that yeah
yeah
there's work to do that's for sure
when when jesus was in the in the
gethsemane
and um and he asked god to take that
chalice away from him
how do you think most christians
understand that today oh it was a moment
of weakness
it was just the human jesus that
suddenly was there but then went away no
no it it was not a moment it's an
ever-present reality drinking from that
chalice
is tough stuff
it's tough to be a real christian
yeah if you know what i mean no i
thought yeah
it's not that romantic thing it's
unbearable actually it's unbearable
listening but just reading the words of
christ is unbearable it's
it's a it's it's it's very difficult
that's why we we read them but we it's
hard to really read what christ asks of
us because it's really unbearable i
agree so the challenge is how do we
recover
the ritual
the sacralization of this world the
ensoment of this world through ritual
without this trap of
romanticizing and lyricizing it to a
point where it becomes unattainable and
becomes different from reality it
becomes spirituality
you see what i'm struggling with
um i can't even describe the problem let
alone find a solution um
that that's the issue right now for me
yeah well i mean i think that in
i think that in a proper kind of
balanced christian life you there is a
there's an aspect of the christian life
which is celebratory
and that's important but there's also an
aspect of the christian life which is
which is penance and repentance constant
repentance so if you take the prayers
that you do every day seriously
it's like you're constantly seeing how
you're missing the mark and even
unwillingly with you know when you're
you're constantly kind of
in that moment of missing and so those
two extremes held in balance i think are
what make it bearable
because if you just had one then you
have the romantic part if you just have
the other
then you would just you just collapse
you just collapsed under the weight of
of of what it means right and so i think
that having those two
having those two in intention is
probably the the best
but at the same time
you know if
occasionally i do go to church
um
and it has
partly to do with my self-nurturing and
partly to do with some kind of
anthropological project see what's
happening in the culture
uh
then there is a way in which
that in which transcendence has become
cartoonified
it has been turned into a cartoon
and
one of the mechanisms i suspect are
partly responsible for this is turning
religion into a moral recipe alone
so a moral code is no longer a
consequence of religion religious inside
it now is religion yeah and that's a way
to cartoonify the whole thing if you do
the right thing my son you will have
eternal life that's a cartoonification
of the whole thing and and to some
extent it's been done by the church this
cartoonification
uh
you see what i'm trying to oh i totally
agree and i don't i'm waving my way here
but no no i don't agree but sadly i have
to i like i'm watching the time go by i
need to go because someone is waiting
for two minutes but i would love to
continue this conversation with you
bernardo and mark thanks for
thanks for for for organizing this it's
always wonderful to to talk to you as
well so
i'm i'm afraid i have to i have to leave
you
all right it was great it was great to
me to talk to both you and uh ronaldo
let's let's let's do this again let's do
this again maybe i can be more coherent
next time no no no it's great i know
exactly what you're pointing to and so
we can explore that i'll i'll i'll also
meditate on it from in my own life let's
say
all right bye everybody thank you
thank you take care
actually
yeah thank you
and did you ever see terence malek's a
hidden light about franzia i guess that
or
no
oh you must watch it you know just what
you're outlined there
it's about a franchise in austria during
the second world war when he refused to
play as an oath of allegiance to hitler
and the consequences
and it shows that kind of
pristine
pseudo-christianity versus his embodied
living out the christian way in this
messy but very real and visceral
form so i think you'd love it actually
yeah it's a brilliant movie
recent one 2019. yeah i think you would
enjoy it and more than just enjoy it it
actually is a transmotix
movies i think are quite um challenging
and
change your your mindset and
i watch it tonight it's with bruno guns
one of my favorite uh
actors oh brilliant so and i think that
would actually help a little bit with
your queries there
about this kind of
a neat christianity versus the authentic
thing
yeah
i watch it tonight um i'm supposed to go
down have dinner now and i probably put
it on if i can access it i'm sure i'm
sure there will be a way for me to
access this yeah you can get it on
amazon prime if you have amazon oh i
have it okay yes we have it i'll get it
there and thanks for the tip i will
watch it yeah please let me know what
you think
i hope you found it as game moving as i
did but uh i would love to say to
whether you want to do a separate
conversation with jonathan or whether
you want to come back onto my channel
i'd love to set that up because say do
this again like part two there is no no
need to
change the recipe when when it works
right so
yeah wonderful god bless you bernardo
have a lovely evening
you too thanks for this mark take care
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your
usual podcast platform but we also have
a website with a blog and several very
interesting articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking about
symbolism on all kinds of subjects we
also have a clips channel a facebook
group you know there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more involved in
the exploration and the discussion of
symbolism don't forget that my brother
matsuya wrote a book called the language
of creation which is a very powerful
synthesis of a lot of the ideas that
explore and so please uh go ahead and
explore this world you can also
participate by you know buying things
that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support